I am
[Music]
middle child two brothers were actually
very close but they lived in different
states only child childhood obsessions
Christmas magic
my name is Michael you're a great dancer
you're a terrible liar and that's kid
I've always imagined that my life was
like a typical romantic comedy you were
so confident and you just ripped off
your clothes like your stupid
bachelorette party and I basically
shower with clothes on
don't just shut up now shall we go to
your place tonight there's my door
before we go in just open the door okay
what is this Michael oh you don't want
to oh my God they're in here too
I think you're very cool and I'm worried
that you're going to break my heart you
know I'm mad this is my friend Mike a
friend yes Mom just a friend what is
going on here who is this guy he's my
boyfriend your boyfriend
I think it's a great kid we may not look
like it but we are actually kind of hip
oh my God we were gonna go to Woodstock
you know
it's fine I am let's just take a moment
to appreciate this beauty
okay what is going on are you all right
come down off the ledge Mike I'm seeing
a doctor tomorrow
I'm afraid the news isn't good
[Music]
I was always afraid kit would break my
heart and eventually he did
you broke it open
you have to run the race in front of you
because that's all there is looking back
this is less of a rom-com and more of a
love story you can't sit for four hours
we promised all the beds are occupied
get my husband a bed well that was Oscar
worthy worked for Shirley MacLaine
I'm sorry I never told you how good your
ass looks in your khaki pants I was
afraid if you understood how beautiful
you are if you'd leave me thank you for
inviting us it was a kid's idea I was
vehemently opposed to it
[Music]
and like all love stories it never
actually ends